[Music]
[Applause]
yes I'm on TV you got to because usually
I always get like this feedback hum
Moschino yeah yeah you must have maybe
higher here
so so with this presentation I will
explain how the distinctive
characteristics of abduction technology
make it simultaneously a very powerful
regulation technology so a tool to
actually implement specific regulatory
objectives but also a powerful tool for
potentially trying to escape regulation
and so first I will describe the
regulatory challenges that are faced by
blockchain technology
mostly to the fact that there is no
centralized authority to regulate and
then we will look into the governance of
production network in order to see how
the different modalities of government
can actually contribute to regulating of
influencing the operations and
activities on this network but from the
inside and the outside of the network
and then at the end we don't receive the
the extent to which production
technology could potentially be used as
these regulatory technology in order to
rely on technological guarantees in
order to achieve policy objectives so in
95 Joel Hayden Bell from Clemson
University introduced the notion of flex
informatica to express the idea that on
the Internet code is increasingly being
used as a way to regulate individual
behavior and so code is law because the
code actually assumes the same function
of the law
I mean to of course this code remains
under the control of specific
intermediary operators which are
themselves subject to the rule of the
law and then on a blockchain code is
also being used to regulate individual
behaviors the difference is that this
time given this specificities of this
blockchain code the technology can be
used to establish a series of self
executive all rules which can to some
extent
ignore the heels of the law and so in
this sense they only know that actually
matters in these systems is the code
that has been deployed and adoption and
so
this has two important implications one
is that production technology reduce the
needs for intermediaries of trusted
alternative because it shifted cast away
from the centralized operator of the
worlds the underlying technology and
this means that to explain that we can
actually trust the underlying technology
then we might no longer need to trust
anyone else and then we will see later
what does it mean to trust production
technology and then the other limb that
it creates new possibilities of
increasing the automation and the
autonomy of those auction-based systems
because once a particular piece of code
has been deployed on deduction then it
can operate autonomously and
independently of the will of the parties
that are deployed it and so this leads
to potential conflicts between the rule
of law and the rule of code and so we
will analyze what is the interplay
between those two types of regulation
regulation by code and regulation by law
and to which extent one is potentially
overtaking the other so can blockchain
based system be forced to comply with
the law or can they instead be used to
escape existing regulatory frameworks to
the extent that they operate within
their own separate technical framework
and so if we back up a little and we
look at the negatives from the ugly
internal days then we might remember
some of the claims of the ugly internet
pioneers like John Terry Bellefleur
osteotomy who saw the cyberspace as an
independent space that simply could not
be regulated because government did not
have the height of the capacity to exert
the sovereignty of the hips but of
course those visions did not really
materialize like those pioneers had
hoped because as soon as the opportunity
of the Internet became to be understood
by the established players then the
architecture of the Internet network is
slowly started to evolve into a
increasingly concentrated system which
is controlled by a few incumbents and so
in a few years the internet which was
initially seen as a powerful tool to
promote individual freedom and autonomy
as eventually become a tool of
surveillance and control after the
initial fear I mean there was worth five
big companies still government would
want to use it initially that was this
this discussion within like the the
academic field about legs informatica
which was it's very hard to regulate the
cyberspace but in fact because of the
because of the intermediaries that are
establishing themselves on the Internet
then it became quite obvious that it's
actually easy to regulate Internet
instead of trying to regulate every
individual user we can regulate the
architecture we can regulate the code
that those operators are actually
deploying on the internet so instead of
having this dehydrogenation we have an
indirect regulation via the technology
but because we and but the reason we can
do that is because we have doesn't
immediately potato that we can identify
and that we have sovereignty over this
is the pathetic dot theory of Lawrence
Lessig from Harvard University will
basically show how individuals are
constantly being regulated by those four
different forces the market law social
norms and architecture of code in the
digital world
and how on the Internet code has become
this kind of privileged Fox used to
influence and regulate the behavior of
Internet users and then the law simply
indirectly regulates user by regulating
the technology now the question is
whether the same solution can actually
apply to a blockchain based system and
the problem here is that with a
blockchain because of the intermediation
and decentralization that that it
implies then we lose this most effective
tool of regulation which have the
intermediary operators and so if we
don't have those intermediary operators
any more than ethnical it becomes much
harder to leverage the traditional means
of regulation that were available on the
Internet because we can no longer easily
identify what is the object of this
regulation and so when we are talking
about the regulation of the Internet
then people introduce the notion of a
regular bility to highlight the
complexity inherent in the regulation of
such a decentralized and transnational
network like the internet and then with
lunch and then some people now are
referring to
platforms as being illegal in the sense
that they operate outside of the truth
view of the law and the idea is that a
blockchain implements its own technical
framework that operates according to its
own rules and that cannot be touched or
affected by the law so we can already
see a few applications of blockchain
technology that are in direct conflict
with existing regulations and too many
of those application leverage tips
anonymity of Bitcoin of other
cryptocurrencies in order to facilitate
money laundering in order to set up some
decentralized marketplaces for the
trading of illicit goods and then more
recently we also found that the tamper
resistant feature and the imitability of
a blockchain system can actually lead to
the storage of illicit content like
copyright infringement or hate speech
ever needs to child pornography and also
potentially prevent the exercise of
specific Heights that require the
deletion of content such as the gdpr had
to be forgotten and so this distinction
between the reel of flow and the reel of
code is actually quite apparent in the
context of poverty the property rights
are defined by the law and the fact they
can be taken away by the law
so if I've acquired a particular piece
of property
in a way that appears to be illegitimate
then a court of a judge can declare that
I'm not the legitimate owner of this
property and potentially seize it from
me
and when we move into a blockchain based
system then we have this concept of
blockchain bills poverty or
cryptographic assets they do not
actually follow the same rules because
the ownership of those assets is not
defined by the law but rather by the
code and the father it can only be taken
away by the court and so even if I
illegitimately acquire a Bitcoin than
regardless of what the law says then no
one actually has the technical capacity
of seizing it from me unless they could
actually provide for that and then the
same applies in the field of contracts
so traditional legal contracts are
treated according to specific rules
which are defined by contract law and
they are meant to create binding
agreements between two parties and those
contracts need to be enforced by a third
party Authority which has to interpret
the wording of the contract in order to
understand what is the actual intentions
of the parties and then in the context
of a swap contract the actual
contractual relationship is defined by
the code of the smut contract and it no
longer requires any third party
enforcement because the position of this
mob contract will be automatically
endorsed by the technology itself and
yet the problem here is that the
technology obviously cannot account of
the real intentions of the parties but
only we look at the
actual working of the code and so
perhaps the best example of fantasy
distinction between the rule of law and
the rule of code has been provided by
the doll so I think I don't need to
explain exactly what happened but
basically the doll was this
decentralized investment fund that was
deployed as a smart contract on the
aterna blockchain back in 2016 and the
idea was that it was collectively
managed by the investor themselves who
could participate in the decision-making
as to which project to invest in
depending on the amount of money that
they had invested into the fund and so
because there was no centralized
authority every interaction with the
doll was done via a smart contract
transaction and so one day someone
identified the nobility in the code of
the Smurf contractor running the Dow and
Exploited it in order to take away 60
million dollars and so this raised a
very heated debate within the eternam
community concerning whether or not this
action actually qualified as a test in
the sense that it actually won counter
to the original intention of the parties
whether it could be regarded as a
legitimate action insofar as it actually
did not go counter to the bugging of the
code of this map contract and so even
though most people will probably agree
that it qualified as a test the
transaction could not be reverted as it
could have done in the traditional
financial system because there was no
central authority then one could not
rely on the traditional legal system in
order to enforce the law
and so in this case the autonomy of the
image imitability of the blockchain code
actually made it impossible for any
topic authority to seize the stolen
assets and so the only way to remediate
the start was for the young community to
take a coordinated action in order to
change the underlying protocol of the
Italian blockchain and so this
essentially shows that no blockchain is
an island
in this sense that abduction does not
subsist on its own but it exists between
a much larger ecosystem and so even if
we cannot rely on the traditional means
of regulation as blockchain technology
becomes more widely and adopted as a
infrastructure then intervention will
become necessary in the case one could
say that the arbitrator was the market
because it led to right a fork yes and
I'm gonna go to that so so basically if
we cannot rely on these traditional
means of regulation then what are the
new avenues for intervention and so well
first of all that is the traditional
intermediaries
so because blockchain systems are
actually built on top of the existing
Internet they can defer be affected by
this traditional intermediaries like ESP
which could apply packet filtering or
other technique to limit the access to a
blockchain network at the same time the
results so the need for people to use a
variety of intermediaries like search
engines of social network in order to
discover the application that might rely
on a blockchain and then doesn't
immediately have the possibility to
somehow limit the adoption of this
application but making them more
difficult to find and we have seen these
already in the case of both Google and
Facebook which began to sense off some
activity related to blockchain
especially in the context of token sales
and then we also see the emergence of
new intermediaries so we have
cryptocurrencies exchanges used to trade
version based assets and so even to a
blockchain based network is it says
decentralized and even totally is a
growing number of decentralized
exchanges that are being built the most
majority of turbulence exchange of
actually operated by large companies
incorporated in a particular
jurisdiction and the fact they are
obliged to comply with the law of the
jurisdiction especially with regard to
know your crystal meth and
money laundering regulation and then we
have the miners and the mining pools
which are the transaction costs of and
so we have seen in over the past year
this growing consolidation of a few
loving pool which have become
identifiable intermediaries and which
could potentially be regulated and we
have we starting to see this type of
regulation coming up but in China and in
the US which are actually attempting to
restrict the activities of some of the
mining pool either by increasing the tax
by actually limiting the quantity of
energy that is provided exactly what you
mean by intermediaries the actors that
you can identify and that are providing
access providing a service the valves
the network so you have like the ISPs an
intermediary to talk to the Internet
those are intermediaries to access
information and then keep the currency
exchange an intermediary attacks and
that we need to use them in order to
exchange Kentuckians in fiat and then
the mining for maybe in the mine field
is not a perfect intermediary but it's
it's a it's a large identifiable
intermediary that can be regulated
yep yeah I don't maybe what a different
painting since the late nineties
maybe this but what what confused me
basically who are those new types of
operator that are emerging around the
network which becomes gateways and which
you depend upon them in order to either
access the network of access a
particular service related to the
network
[Music]
and now the user is to choose their own
intermediaries but at the time we
propose to do it with Bitcoin vaults
that allow you to cancel payment there
is the hydro project from Phil Diane and
company and Cornell tech that loves to
overcome bugs before go before it
reaches the point where you have to that
to go to the miner you can choose your
own intermediaries in the case of major
failure you can tell them something
something fishy is going on here this
group can decide for everything so this
is creating new cluster intermediation
that people can choose that's same thing
with I mean always what I'm talking tell
me that is you get to chose them
now if except for the regulation of new
established intermediaries there is also
other types of possible intervention one
is criminalizing end-users in the sense
that government can actually prevent
people from accessing of interacting
with a particular block chain of
interacting with a particular illness
it's not compact of course it's very
hard to identify who the users are
because of the pseudonymous nature of
this network and it is also oftentimes
not such a good idea to target directly
on Jesus as we have seen in the past
with like the copyright works against
piracy
mostly because those often times
translating to extremely high Kony on
type of regulations which very often go
and impinge upon the Kivus fee of
individual and require this kind of like
surveillance in order to be able to
identify every single action done by
the end users and then the other
alternative is to actually impose
liability on software developer so how
do our manufacturers and I guess we will
have Angela Walsh that will focus on
Dean specifically and here the idea is
that government cooled for developers to
incorporate specific bug talks or kill
switches and again we have seen deals
already attempted in the past with the
US and the world about children happy
with the keeper chip where government
was trying to regulate the manufacturer
how how about device in order to
incorporate a particular backdoor
obviously creating the risk of
vulnerabilities just curious why
hardware and software developers are not
here intermediaries like providing a
device but then the device can be used
by anyone on the home local level it's
not an intern idea is something that
exists in the middle and is it the
gateway so they are there they are
providing us they're providing tools
that are touching the data so I guess I
see your point
it's like saying the computer the Apple
is an intermediate because it has
computer as opposed to Google being an
intermediary because I need to rely on
Google to access specific services okay
thank you
so now comes the a lot of types of
possible regulatory lava which is
market-based regulation so of course
there is the obvious 51% attack which is
probably very unlikely because it will
generally require several billions of
dollars you know the like to attack one
of those networks but potentially T's is
definitely within the reach of state
wave actors alternative metal is the
possibility of trying to manipulate the
market by trying to affect the value of
a particular cryptocurrency in order to
create instability and potentially
destroy the use of the related
blockchain and then there is this mark
imagine discussion around network
neutrality are like blockchain
neutrality basically because the help of
specific actors within the network on
the one hand we have - which design can
be analogize with Internet service
provider in the sense that they are
these transaction processors that
register transaction in the block and
they are in theory completely oblivious
as to the type the source or the
destination of the transaction that are
processing because they essentially only
care about blocks world and transaction
fee but it is quite possible that either
government or because of external
contractual agreements then - might be
required to enforce specific field such
as ignoring a particular type of
transactions that are coming or going to
a particular account plus preventing
them to cause us to build upon any block
in which such a transaction has actually
been incorporated and so if it is
possible to actually control over 50
percent of the mining power to follow
the same rules then it actually becomes
possible to send some transactions
without like without actually leaving
any visibility because there's actually
no protocol change and then on the other
hand
he is like those students which are
those active that actually have a
particular type of influence on a
blockchain network so there's our
exchanges does abduction Explorer from
like custodian wallet basically any
commercial operator that interact to the
blockchain which again has are also the
possibility of refusing of accepting
specific transaction coming from a
particular account that they have the
capacity of creating block block a
whitelist tells of the power to accept
or reject a particular protocol change
in the case of a sock and every user
that actually want to continue
interacting with those actor will then
follow that particular [ __ ] and then
finally on perhaps what is one of the
most effective ways of intervention of
regulation of publishing system is a
social norms in the sense that we have
already seen the influence that social
norms have in the governments of
specific grab block consistent so we can
see the the contrast from Bitcoin which
has this collective desire of achieving
almost perfect imitability so really
abiding by the CODIS law paradigm versus
idiom which actually focus more on
distributed consensus and as shown to be
much more willing to modify the protocol
in order to fix a particle of a harness
or illegitimate transaction if these
will have negative impact on the network
or perhaps on society at large so if we
go back to last week framework then we
can see that even though it might be
more challenging on a blockchain system
for the law to regulate the
infrastructure of a blockchain we can
nonetheless rely on the new level of
intervention which is social norms and
so these highlight the importance of
duction governance which I think will
actually play a very important role in
the way in which the technology will
evolve and so now we now provide a small
overview of
various active and loyal spouses that
contribute to the government's in
abruption system so first of all it is
important to distinguish between the
governance by the infrastructure what is
usually called ancient governments which
basically refers to all the fields that
are back directly into the technology
and which are enforced by the technology
and here the focus is on the enforcement
of the peers as opposed to on the
elaboration of those words and then
government of the infrastructure which
is often government's which relate to
the most social and institutional layers
by which those rules are elaborated
before they actually embed into the
technology as well as all the procedures
that are necessary to decide how to
change those rules if needed and then
for each one of those categories we can
also distinguish between endogenous
fuels which are developed by the
community and for the community
and exogenous fuels which are actually
imposed by a property of the community
and so initially most of the focus was
on endogenous untrained governments
basically looking at how we can use
blockchain technology to incorporate
specific fields directly into the
technological fabric of a particular
system whether that's through the
blockchain protocol of mud contracts and
then eventually it has become more
obvious that it is just as important if
not more important to think about often
governments and this includes all the
social norm institutional arrangement
that actually makes it possible for the
hills to evolve and to adapt to the
community's needs and so the importance
of efficient governance has been visible
by two governments crisis that the ETM
community has faced so on the one hand
the DAO hoc which actually led to the
community to make an intervention in
order to change the protocol to retrieve
the funds and then the other one was the
party bug which was the exploitation of
a bug in multisig as much contract we
led to over 300 million dollars worth of
ether to be frozen on the blockchain and
again here it created a lot of debate
within the community as to whether we
should change the protocol in order to
release those funds and as opposed to
the doubt which actually led to a
collective intervention and in the case
of this problem then the decision was
not to intervene and so there who have
many discussion and many reasons why not
but one of the reason was because while
the DAO attack was done as an emergency
just like a state of exception doing it
again would necessarily require creating
an actual procedure actually specifying
and formalizing the way in which
decisions need to be taken about whether
or not to modify the protocol to fix a
problem and so there was this fear that
if such a procedure is actually
formalized then all of students there
who will actually be legal liability
associated with it in the sense that it
will become visible that the community
and especially the people that get to
decide within this passage whether or
not to change the protocol actually have
influence and have the capacity to
decide whether or not to change the
protocol and effort to collect back some
funds and many of the people that were
actually involved within the discussion
they actually did not want to make such
a political decision because they were
they were used to only dealing with like
technical issues and so there was a lot
of fear of faction legal liability which
led to the decision we should not
intervene on this one and so basically
because if you create a positive so you
have like in any tyranny of the interim
improvement proposal process and you
have like some proposal editors that
essentially decide whether these
proposals should be assessed or not and
then some people from the community
mostly like the code F they will decide
whether or not to accept this proposal
and so in this case by formalizing this
Presidium not just for technical issue
but also for political or legal
questions then all of student those
people that make the decision could be
first possibly considered to be liable
so for instance if I lost my if I did a
mistake and I lost my my ETA then I
could make a proposal to you we need to
change the protocol because I need to
recover my ETA and if they decide not to
but they decided to do it for other
cases then I could have a recourse
against them it wouldn't apply to the
DAO attack with the people who decided
that not all tactical point it was a
state of exception it was a it was a it
was justice or something had to be
decided and the it was like it had done
in a completely informal way nobody
really knows how these things has been
decided now in the case of poverty
because there was no urgency the the
only way you can decide is actually you
need to make a process and so as you
create a process and as you formalize
the governance for the city in deciding
on this question then all of student
people are identified at the different
levels and you know who is actually
making the decisions for example the
person who you know put that it's a
parody smart contract probably there's
like identifiability you can probably
identify in the get exactly the person
who would they be
but the same logic wouldn't they already
reliable I mean we have done we actually
did that the thing is that there has not
been any cop there's not be any justice
action in justice afar so it's really
hard to tell we've done a mood curve on
the DAO attack just to see like we took
like some judges from Florida and we did
like we pretended that someone who are
actually seeing the developer of this
math contract and at the end like
there's a two or three hour discussion
and at the end the judges actually
decide that they could not take refused
to give a verdict because they just
didn't understand anything like it's
just completely it is so out of the
their mind so yes possibly you could see
because they have done an air Hawking
that but even if you see them they won't
be able to pay back 300 million dollars
so the only way you can actually get
those funds back is by actually changing
the infrastructure all right so the you
can always see people and then they will
give you whatever money and damages you
can get from them but the money is
actually still stuck in the blockchain I
don't understand why it follows that
there couldn't have been an informal
process after the ferry but because
there was no looming deadline still they
could have on the span of a few weeks
just like the Dow decided that there was
going to be two competing but we thought
it definitely did not want to decide on
that I mean the difference the Dow it's
really hard to tell who was taking the
decision no one Phileas taking the
decision it just happened that the
network followed the particular decision
sure the exact same process that worked
for the Dow could have been applied to
parody the fact that there was no
deadline doesn't preclude that they
could have just made some informal
right and if there had been an informer
decision Carlita would have been a [ __ ]
it just didn't happen so this may be the
decision was an informal decision not to
do anything but within the actual
aetherium community there was this
discussion as to what do we do because
it is just to example but there will be
many like as this technology gets used
modern walk it's gonna happen a lot that
people are doing a half in the way in
which they do this math contract and
there will be some losses and every time
you cannot just every time rely on an
informal cosa so either you ignore and
you say we actually don't want to have
any type whether its formal or informal
that is just no intervention possible
because it's a it's a blockchain and
it's imitable all we actually accept the
fact that intervention is possible but
if you if you accept the fact that
information is possible then obviously
you need to say when intervention is
possible who is to decide one to do it I
guess I just don't buy you say like that
they can't just have an informal process
every time but they do have an informal
process every time so like you're saying
something's not possible that is exactly
what they've done with parity has
decided they have decided to keep this a
completely informal system and the
informality of the system has led to not
no intervention but they refuse to
create a formalized structure because of
the fear of like Chile showing that they
do have the power or that there are some
people that do have the power to make an
intervention I come at this from a
lawyer right not a computer science
brain but they are they have to be
concerned not just about legal liability
but presidential issues as you were
saying but I also wonder and what point
does it become centralized right I mean
I think they I think the trust in the
decentralized system is really at risk
if you're having roommates
I think in some way like that's why it's
kind of weird to talk about from an
environment that even if there is a
formalised caused us not everybody needs
to follow there's no coercion anyhow so
it wouldn't be even if they attend your
foundation creates its own process for
deciding when to intervene but then no
nodes actually accept the decision then
there is a formal process that is not
actually adopted so it I don't think it
can really be centralized in that sense
but if they do actually list and then
it's dangerous because then you can
actually claim that they do have power
even though it's it still it's not a
full power because it's not a coercive
power
I would say they still have power and
they demonstrated every time they do a
protocol aspirate that is technical they
have whatever it's still an informal
process it gets executed like clockwork
however you see the big point for
example where no formal structure exists
yet every protocol upgrade pretty much
goes through as well and it's agreed
upon by a lot of people so you could
argue but they are liable for not
reversing parity because they can still
do it they do it for technical things
this is something that the solvable via
technical means so I'm not sure I would
confer any protection on this it's an
argument like the argument is we are
like if you do something obviously you
have shown that you can do it if you
have not done anything you don't have a
proof that you could have done something
right now with the with the improvement
proposal there is an actual formal
process of how it works and but it's
it's actually designed for technical
question and no one within at this stage
no one within the ETM improvement
proposal actually wanted to make any
decision that was not a technical
decision and and and some of the EIP
editors actually left just because of
that because they didn't want to be
involved in that process so bitcoin
against I have like the Bitcoin
improvement proposal and there is not
always a consensus as we have seen
VidCon forking in many other sub
networks so whether like you can always
have a you can always have a formal
proposal but of course that doesn't
actually mean because there is no
coercive power that doesn't mean that
the decision will actually be taken and
people can [ __ ] on in in any direction
anyway so there is this web type of
power it's not full power it's you have
influence but you don't feel your power
so I want to ask you a hypothetical
since there was some VIP editors as
identifiable that made changes for the
DAO attack like let's say there's a list
of people
actually were attributed to that change
the bug wants to Yeti and then that's
where the problem came in because people
refused was done in a very urgent manner
and it was it went into the informal
process like people tied like some there
is some public you could identify a few
people that had to change I mean the
Dakar developer implemented that they
are far and then people decided to take
it
parody basically sooo the core
developers who made changes for the dam
attack under your argument that well
they made a change to fix above that you
know restore justice for the people who
lost money here so they should make a
change to restore to you know restore
justice for the people who lost money
there I mean if they could do it but I
know because they what they do is
providing a tool and then you still need
user to adopt this tool like any any
crowd developer I can do anything I want
of not doing anything I want and like
positi could have developed the solution
as well it could have proposed into the
Hoenn client the solution to the cavity
bug but then if no one is actually
accepting that or adopting it into the
home client and it doesn't matter I
don't think I don't think parity would
have any kind of claim over the author
code of okay so I guess the distinction
you make is quite subtle it's that if
there was a formal process then there
would be identifiable P but since there
isn't one and you can't even make up
some argument that like the people who
did it before were the same you just
know that called a blog created would
get it up people
there really are my I mean that would be
that will not be a hard win because you
will have to justify that they actually
had influence and they could prove that
I actually have no power about what the
user will decide to remind us who used
to implement on the Mac it's it's not
such a easy case I wonder if this is
actually I mean we've had discussions
about plank legalities I just wonder if
this was the case of your social norms
this is kind of a signal by the
developers initially where we're putting
a little bit with the Dow fact they were
signaling that there is some openness we
are openness trying to put some other
things in the side but then with the
Perry buckets but they said alright
we're we're you know we're just still
playing decentralisation czar focus I
wonder if that's a better framework what
do you think any comment if you had
comments on this idea that it's it's
just like the signal the signal that
people are trying to stand with this
with these decisions
there's many reason why this has been
decided well why informal it has been
decided not to intervene the the legal
ability is one of them the the fact of
not wanting to show that he is a
possibility that there is an actual
process for changing because most of the
credibility of the blockchain comes from
the fact that it's immutable and if all
of sudden you start treating of course
for meet ability then some people might
no no no no longer trust disruption
right so there is many reason like
including like weather like this what
does this committed consensus means like
do we want to just if anyone agrees then
we can change anything or do we still
have some cognitive about code is law
and things like that so the the social
norm of it you know of course they also
don't want to show that everything can
change I'll be hardly by a few percent
part of a process so it's it's it's a
very complex decision because on the one
hand there is a desire of creating some
level of
risk management if there is like very
drastic problems opening on the network
but at the same time you don't want it
to become like the decision of a few
people like if there was a process it
will be able to it will it will have to
be a very complex and kind of like
democratic process with like separation
of power annalisa like you basically
need to recreate traditional
institutions so that no one is actually
liable because everyone is part of the
decision height but because there is no
like there is no governance in any term
at the moment that is that can be
democratic because we don't even know
who the people are so you cannot even
are can ask the users to express
themselves it's basically just - it's
really it's a very complex question it
like the whether or not and how to deal
with possible mistakes in the court and
whether whether there is actually a
possibility to create a system that will
enable those to overcome specific
problems without actually falling into a
system that then no that can no longer
claim to be trustless
so so basically those case highlights
the importance of exogenous trails but
with regard to the fact that
asmath contract the operation of a smart
contract can actually be affected by the
underlying network which in this case is
deduction Network and so this guarantee
of execution is actually only guaranteed
to the extent that the protocol does not
change and on the other hand is also the
question of all the non technical fields
from outside of the community most
importantly laws and regulation which
even if they cannot affect directly the
the actor on the the network they can
nonetheless exert some kind of crusher
over the community of people that do
have influence over this network and so
basically this shows how the the
blockchain governance is essentially
multi-layered governance concepts where
we have the crowd developers at the top
which basically providing the possible
choices of changes that then the other
participants of the network can choose
from and then at the bottom we have the
notes whether they - or the validators
we can select some of the possible
choices that have been offered to them
but based on what they actually want but
also based on the perception of what the
author wants because the network is only
valuable to the extent that there is
actually a sufficient amount of people
that are give it to the same protocol
and then outside of that we also have
other type of influencers that basically
tried to establish business in this
selling point and the lack of course the
mining pool that can aggregate - in
power of individual - deserve the suburb
notes crypto currency exchange block
exponent so far and then to have the
people which can either be those
charismatic leaders which have the
highest degree of credibility of all the
social media influencers which can hire
and lobby for one particular change or
the other
and so in terms of regulation by code
then we can see that blockchain systems
do provide at least interval stronger
guarantees than traditional internet
platforms because there is no
centralized authority that can intervene
to impose a particular decision to the
users but at the same time the system
actually governed by a very large
community of actor which are involved in
the development in the operational in
the maintenance of the network and which
are all trying to influence each other
to adopt a particular protocol over the
other without whoever never having any
possibility of corruption and so
basically how does the governance open
and this goes to your question so the
most popular type of blockchain
governments at the moment is based on
like market-based governments basically
relying on market dynamics in order to
coordinate individuals without any
centralized Authority and so essentially
this means that we are most most system
operators a plutocracy where the
influence is based on the amount of
resources without a sheen power
cryptocurrency holdings that a person
can acquire and did actually make sure
because the free market is indeed a
powerful mechanism for obtaining
distributed consensus but of course as
we have seen over the years market can
also easily be manipulated by powerful
actors and unless we do actually have an
institution that can protect the
competitiveness of the market then
oftentimes they evolve into an
oligopolistic system and so when we talk
about the governance of locking
technology it is also important to
distinguish between the decentralization
of the infrastructure and the
centralization of power over this
infrastructure and most importantly it
is important to understand that the
decentralization of the infrastructure
will not necessarily lead to a
decentralization of power and in fact it
can be the contrary because a
decentralized infrastructure
is oftentimes weaker than a centralized
infrastructure because there is no
institution that can protect it then it
can easily be co-opted by the most
powerful actors and so one left to the
invisible hands of the market then many
blockchain based system are likely to
evolve into increasingly centralized
system potentially with the emergence of
new intermediaries of potato that my
progressively intermediate the world
system just like it up and we date on it
and and the worst thing is further
exacerbated by the issue of the tyranny
of structured lessness which often
emerge in communities that do not have a
formalized government structure in a
centralized system the hierarchical
structure is is transparent so people
can know who are the people in power and
the activity can be monitored so that
there can be no abuses of power there is
some kind of accountability well at in a
decentralized system power actually
often consolidate into those invisible
structure but the underlying power
dynamics are actually not a pattern that
is like those invisible powers and
emerge but it's really difficult for
people to understand who is actually
accountable for what and this is what
happened with with the data attack there
was people that actually had specific
power and influence over the network but
it's really hard for anyone using the
network to actually know how the
decision was actually being made and so
the main takeaway is that government
should actually never be analyzed in a
static manner because it is essentially
a dynamic process that evolves over time
and power often times shift from one
place to the other and so if the goal is
to create a decentralized system with a
decentralized governments then it is
oftentimes not enough to stop with a
level playing field I can system where
everyone starts equal because the
accumulation of high sources over time
will actually create the centralization
of a recent transaction of power and so
the the department that is actually
nothing natural of spontaneous about the
decentralization of power and
distributing power within a community
actually requires governments and
potentially regulation to ensure that
the power does not concentrate into the
hands of a few and this is something
that is currently lacking in most
Russian community and if I have do I
still have two minutes because you'll
actually like I just wanna spend a few
meters and design giggles is actually
the thing that I'm the most interested
to share and to receive feedback on and
it's the potential of actually using
production technology as a regulatory
technology and so basically we shift
from the idea of code is law where we
have private actors which are using the
technology to regulate behavior to the
idea of code as law where blockchain
technology can be used as a regulatory
technology to achieve specific policy
objectives and so logically and this
relates to the torque from this morning
the idea is that we can potentially use
technology to ensure regulatory
compliance by promoting more
transparency auditability
of accountability in specific factors
and the goal of course is not to codify
or implement legal rules into a
technological framework but rather to
translate those legal constraints into
technological guarantees and so the idea
behind functional equivalents is to
identify policy or regulatory objectives
that motivated the creation of a
particular set of regulations and then
looking at whether the same policy or
regulatory objectives can be fulfilled
with technical rather than legal means
there were in order to provide some kind
of alternative form of compliance for
technical instead of legal means and so
on our general levels of course is the
idea of using production technology as a
digital audit trail to keep record of
all the important transaction so that
auditor of can later rely on this
information without having to trust the
company
for the data it provides because the
company simply could not tamper with the
data and this is specifically useful for
instance in the context of medical
trials where it is important on the one
hand that we can verify that every step
has been executed as prescribed by the
law but that's on the other hand to
ensure that in case something goes wrong
no one has the power to retro actively
go and notify the result from the test
and then not specifically to financial
institutions we also have seen how
blockchain technology can be used to
reduce the cost of regulatory compliance
by increasing the transparency and
accountability for instance with the
proof of ghazal mechanism / kraken which
allows user to perform a
cryptographically verified audits to
certify that the crypto currency
exchange actually has a full result
without ever disclosing the account the
balance of the individual accounts after
inference using signature to ensure that
the funds cannot be spent without
obtaining the prior authorization and
then another question related to the
gdpr so in spite of all the question
indeed that aria is about the potential
conflict between corruption technology
and the high to be forgotten the results
potentially the possibility of actually
using blockchain technology to provide
some type of verified credentials of
attestation that that could actually
reduce the need for transnational data
flows between different countries and so
instead of transferring data from one
place to the other then people can rely
on those verified attestation to prove
that they actually possess specific
attributes and this could create like
new opportunities for trusted
certification authorities to provide
credential to individuals from Europe
member state in order to enable them to
access services from outside of Europe
without requiring them to disclose the
personal data every time that they want
to interact with a new service and then
finally acquired
Antonio so mostly for like well this is
a hones in on his post so there is a lot
of discussion about the extent to which
we can improve regulatory compliance and
actually prove that on particular
company or entity has complied with
particular regulation but without
disclosing any type of sensitive data
and I would be very curious if you have
any idea of where that is actually
possible and how or if you have any
other idea about what kind of
opportunities does blockchain provide to
achieve specific regulatory objectives
by relying on the technological
guarantees that it provides
doesn't I guess have to wondering what
your view would be on a block came like
eat Fred where the voting mechanism and
the method by which code is changed is
baked into the blockchain itself it
seems like that is another attempt to
realize a system which exists outside of
existing legal framework that there
really is no growth show if everybody on
blockchain is voting for every change in
the code and therefore if that code
doesn't comply with real-world law
there's really nobody to go after yeah
as well and that is the same with like
token voting hashing power is the same
so unless you have like a particular
entity that can decide you basically
just rely on how many people decide to
go on one way or the other and it's I
mean it's been is the same the present
plan you can have a token based
decisions and then people decide to
change the protocol but then if the
miners do not want to change the court
occult is still not gonna change it so
you just have those different layers but
there is no correction possible anyhow
I think that blockchain is not a the
problem is that it does not exist out of
the legal framework recently it is not
its own legal Freeman because even going
back to what we were discussing before
relating to Dow and any possibility for
a court to decide to return money to
which have been solid we have been
akiza's we're already in discounts and
from a measurement order as it's as if
it was in GT marks Japan exported data
they signing them after an attack a
cyber attack or to a blockchain
but complains that they had to return
some of the money so it was a garden
going back to what it was before the
fact is only did it was not revealed in
the blockchain system so the idea is
either we decide and I don't know if I'm
putting from the correct perspective but
at least it was something I can see him
from the legal one is either we decided
we accept allocation of responsibility
and accessibility point as it was before
so we go back to us somehow
centralization where these things and
what new technologies are linked
together or we accept that from this
entry
under the technology perspective we
arrive and we reach out the
centralization of power but to reach the
spine we need them within themselves
decide to how to behave and in the end
we hope people human beings that's
always felt the need to have a power
center or someone good guy
this thing that seems very new the block
chains are doing like 40 and all
department learning the marketer site is
something that actually the human
society is very familiar with for
instance in things that are abstract one
prime example is instance religion or
people you know it's just branch off and
sort of the market decides or another
interesting thought is that you know
maybe someday we'll also see walk
changes as opposed to only have
importance you know you need agreement
to bear size that leaves our date you
know the sort of conversion there was
maybe some exchange rate fixed or the
market fix I mean I think there is
nothing new about the [ __ ] but the
the blockchain system actually provide
more from its like as opposed to the
open source talking it's it's much more
critical to actually [ __ ] on a
blockchain because you have like the
network effect that becomes really like
you can [ __ ] on on open source software
Hannity are stealing - okay how about if
you [ __ ] abductions and you listening
to help ability you lose the value of
the cryptocurrency and so thought so I
think it it it was much more like it so
much harder decision but we're actually
starting a seminar in Paris about
blockchain using theological tools in
order to analyze the the governance of
locking systems
and yeah if you want to come up with
this better speaker and
[Applause]